so on all of this news tonight we are
glad to bring in
vice president mike pence who joins us
from the muskingum county fairgrounds
in zanesville ohio welcome vice
president good to have you with us
tonight
got an enthusiastic crowd behind you
we do great day here in ohio martha it's
good to be with you tonight thank you
all right i hope we're going to be able
to hear your answers um so
if you if we could start with this today
the president came out and said this
about a vaccine and when it will be
available
listen to this we're very close to that
vaccine as soon as the fda approves the
vaccine and as you know we're very close
to that we'll be able to distribute at
least 100 million vaccine doses by the
end of
2020 and a large number much
sooner than that so 100 million by 2020
that's just a couple months away
and he said a large amount before that
so we're now
mid-september toward the end of the year
but this is what the cdc
director dr redfield said earlier today
listen to this
when is it going to be generally
available to the american public
so we can begin to take advantage of
vaccine
to get back to our regular life i think
we're probably looking at third
late second quarter third quarter 2021.
all right so they've gone back and forth
over this and uh dr redfield says that
he was talking about when
everybody would be able to get one
but i want to get specific on this in
terms of how it's going to work because
you ran the coronavirus
task force once the vaccine is available
and we all hope that is very soon
who exactly will get it first and how
many doses will be available say within
the first
few weeks well martha first off it is
remarkable to think that
uh before the month of january was out
the president took unprecedented action
to suspend all travel from china he
stood up the white house coronavirus
task force
but one week later when we received the
first genetic coding of the coronavirus
we started working on a vaccine
i mean you know martha usually it takes
years to develop a vaccine but because
of the leadership
president trump is provided here because
of the incredible work
of our pharmaceutical companies and all
the dedicated men and women
at the fda and the nih we are literally
we think we may well be within a month
or so of having the first
safe and effective coronavirus vaccine
in america okay
so now we're going for the wider world
so it really is extraordinary to think
about it but the other piece of
operation warp speed if i may
is that the president's leadership here
also not only has
has made it possible for us to to move
forward on on the development
of a vaccine in record time but also
we're manufacturing these vaccines as we
speak so the very moment
that one of those companies that are
already in phase three clinical trials
says that it's safe
they submit it to the fda as soon as the
fda
says it's safe and effective we will
have tens of
millions of doses available for the
american people so 10 there's 330
million people in the country
you say that um within what a month
after that approval you think you'll
have tens of millions so who
would be the lucky recipients of those
first tens of million
that could potentially given the time
frame that you're discussing
be available say november-ish
maybe december-ish who are those tens of
millions that would get it right away
and how would that work
well what our team released this morning
is a
a i think 57 page distribution plan
and we're already beginning to work uh
with every state in the country to be
prepared uh for the moment that we have
the fda approval on a safe and effective
vaccine
and let me be very clear on this because
of the president's leadership martha
we're manufacturing these vaccines now
so that the moment the fda says that's a
safe and effective vaccine
we're we're going to have tens of
millions of doses to be able to
distribute immediately now
it'll be up to an agency known as the
acip
that's going to be going through the
process with the very best science and
council to determine
the prioritization and the distribution
of the vaccines
but but you know if if you look at past
practices
as we were talking about at the task
force yesterday we're going to focus on
the most vulnerable we're going to focus
on
doctors nurses first responders
to make sure that the people who are
potentially subject to the worst
outcomes from the coronavirus have the
vaccine first but as the president said
today we expect to have
we're on track to have one or more safe
and effective coronavirus vaccines
before the end of the year we expect to
have if that's the case
a hundred million doses before december
31
and then hundreds of millions of doses
uh the end of this year would be roughly
less than a third of the country would
have the opportunity to
get that vaccine by december 31 you're
saying um
so that that would be great
well remember the the and again i want
to go back to
uh you know you look at the american
innovation in vaccine development
absolutely nobody doubts that i mean we
all know that it's been you know several
years
vaccine for the american people well
look what's going to happen
is that we're going to we're going to
make the vaccine available
uh if if past practice is an indicator
that's what
dr fauci and others talked to us about
yesterday at the task force
when the acip comes out with its
recommendations we expect they'll focus
on seniors with serious underlying
health conditions with any american that
may have
an immunodeficiency anyone who's
vulnerable to a a
very serious outcome with the
coronavirus and then of course making
sure our first responders
doctors nurses healthcare workers
absolutely have access to the vaccine
all right literally tens of millions of
doses but remember that's not the only
medicine here martha
remember we're in the process we've
approved rem desophere
we're just a couple of weeks away from
confirming
uh that the impact positive impact of
convalescent plasma our pharmaceutical
companies have been doing miraculous
work i know joe biden said
no miracle is coming but in america
we're in the miracle business
and we believe we're going to continue
to save lives
and we're going to have a safe and
effective vaccine before the end of this
year you know this this whole dispute
over masks i know the white house just
said that um
there was an earlier story that several
staffers had tested positive we all saw
the very large gathering which was for a
wonderful reason uh yesterday
on the historic middle east peace
agreement um but the early word was that
several staffers had come
tested positive for kovid and now uh
kaylee mcnaney confirmed in the press uh
conference just moments ago that it's
one staffer so obviously
um that's good news uh but with regard
to the whole mask issue
here's what dr redfield said and again
it seems like there's a discrepancy
between
what he's saying and what the president
is saying on this so let's play that for
everybody
we have clear scientific evidence they
work
and they are our best defense i might
even go so far as to say that this face
mask
is more guaranteed to protect me
against covid than when i take a covet
vaccine
more a mask is better than the vaccine
sir
well we think it's always a good idea to
wear a mask
but the american people can be confident
we're going to continue
to drive relentlessly toward having a
safe and effective vaccine
and we're going to continue to drive
toward having medicines and
and it'll be the vaccine ultimately that
that puts the coronavirus
uh in the past i have great respect for
dr redfield and uh
he's a great doctor lead cdc with great
distinction uh but look we we really do
believe the answer here
the antidote here is to have a vaccine
and because of president trump's
leadership
we we literally believe that we will
have
a safe and effective vaccine before the
end of this year and that's what makes
it
so irresponsible for joe biden and his
running mate and other democrats
uh to be talking about not trusting the
vaccine not trusting
president donald trump look the the the
our great pharmaceutical companies are
cutting no corners we've made it clear
we've made
billions of dollars available them to
develop these vaccines
in record time but whether it's the fda
the nih
the advisory board that oversees it the
american people can be confident despite
the
politics that are being played by joe
biden and others
let me ask you about that when we have
that vaccine available it's going to be
safe and effective for the americans so
it does concern you that the numbers of
people who say that they would be
willing to take it according to some
polls that we're looking at have dropped
dramatically down 20 points in in one
poll
that we looked at so i mean that that is
disturbing
and you obviously are concerned about
that as well
well i think it's very irresponsible for
joe biden and kamala harris
to be calling into question the
incredible innovation
of our scientists working around the
clock to develop
vaccines for the american people i mean
look they they know
that there are multiple safeguards in
place
but president trump has made it clear to
all of our pharmaceutical companies
since he brought them into the white
house
very early in this pandemic and said i
want you to develop medicines
i want you to develop vaccines but he
said
no shortcuts were cutting no corners and
the american people can be very
confident despite the politics being
played by joe biden
and his running mate that we're going to
drive toward a safe and effective
vaccine
president donald trump will always put
the health of america first
good to hear um i just want to play one
more sound bite from you
and this is from ayanna presley because
obviously
uh there's been so much racial strife
across the country and we've seen
the the riots and the looting that have
now amounted to a billion dollars in
losses for
cities across this country but she wants
to get the cdc
involved in solving this problem um i'm
going to play that for you
i want to get your reaction on the other
side sir if i may
our bill will establish a law
enforcement violence prevention
program at the center for disease
control police brutality
oh we lost the end of that but she's
essentially saying that she she
thinks that the cdc that there should be
a bill where the cdc would oversee
the negative health effects and an
impact on people's lives
of police brutality in this country
you know martha look the american people
know that men and women serve in law
enforcement so the best people
in this country they put their lives on
the line uh every single day
and while they're you know there's
there's no excuse for what happened to
george floyd and justice will be served
but there's also
there's no excuse for people playing
politics and trying to blame
dedicated law enforcement officers who
are out fighting crime for crime that's
happening
on the streets of our city i mean it's
the reason why president trump has taken
such strong action from very early on
four thousand law enforcement officers
funded in our first
three years through the cops program and
the operation legend program that the
president launched
named after a little boy who was gunned
down in his home
uh is now deployed a thousand federal
officials to our cities
and arrested more than 2 000 violent
protesters who who have burned
businesses threatened individuals and
brought violence
to our streets look we gotta we gotta
reject the notion
that we need to make a choice between
supporting law enforcement
and supporting our african-american
community or minority communities in our
city
president donald trump has done both
from day one
and we're going to continue to support
law enforcement even while we work to
improve the lives of our african
american neighbors more jobs better
public safety
better educational opportunities and
choices
but we've done it so far we're going to
do it for four more years all right
um do you question who you should be
debating on october 7th since uh the
biden harris team seems to keep
flipping around the names of harris
biden and biden harris
no i know who i'm going to be
well i look i i can't wait to get to
that debate stage in salt lake city
because the choice in this election
has never been clear the stakes have
never been higher and i'm looking
forward to laying out our agenda our
vision
with the radical left agenda of uh joe
biden and kamala harris we will see
we will see you there mr vice president
thank you so much for your time tonight
good to see you sir